en este tribunal de Minsk se juzga a
svenoscaya en ausencia por alta traición
y otros cargos algunos de los cuales
dice ni siquiera conoce ya que nunca ha
podido hablar con su abogado se le ha
negado el acceso a los documentos del
tribunal y no se le permite participar
por video en el juicio a Puerta cerrada
exiliada hace dos años y medio desde que
encabezó las masivas protestas
prodemocráticas en belarus la activista
de 40 años habló ante líderes mundiales
en davos según ella su juicio es solo
uno de los muchos intentos de Alexander
lucashenko de reprimir a los disidentes
estos juicios no son juicios en absoluto
es un espectáculo una farsa pero no
tiene nada que ver con la justicia es
una venganza personal de lucashenko y
sus compinches pero no solo contra mí
sino contra otras personas que se le
oponen
el juicio de alto nivel no es el único a
su esposo que vio truncadas sus
aspiraciones presidenciales tras ser
detenido y condenado a 18 años de cárcel
le fueron imputados nuevos cargos el el
premio Nobel encarcelado Alex vialski
también está en el banquillo acusado de
financiar movimientos de la oposición y
comenzó además el juicio del periodista
polaco bielorruso andrey por showbut él
se enfrenta a 12 años de cárcel por
criticar al gobierno de lucashenko El
Alto comisionado para asuntos exteriores
de la Unión Europea Joseph emitió una
voz de alarma en un comunicado afirmando
que la represión ha alcanzado un nivel
sin precedentes los grupos de Derechos
Humanos calculan que más de 1400
personas están en prisión en belarus por
motivos políticos